that's because the stars gay has been
working hard on their tour and it is
looking fantastic it launches tomorrow
in Salt Lake City also in the works max
and Peter's wedding and we got them
gushing over their engagement can we see
this sparkler hold it up for the camera
for us how did you know that this was
forever it was that I couldn't see
myself with anybody else so he's like
literally the love of my life and that's
that's it do you would you say no when I
was proposing would you ever would you
give like me let me think about that no
I would I don't know about love at first
sight than fireworks and oh my god this
is it yeah because we would but we but
we you know it it grew and it grew in it
and it's and we had to work on some
things but at the end of the day we just
love each other and that's that's the
bottom line
but I thought I'm not planning anything
else I'm done you are not planning in
the hub it was zero max and Peter were
raising funds at the winter wonderland
ball benefiting Children's Miracle
Network Hospitals any child can come in
with their parents and get treated for
free no child's gonna be turned away no
expenses cost
you